bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
vendée globe 2016 le versailles et éric
bellion et laurent politain louis burton
viennent d'atteindre le stade de la mi
course sur ce tour du monde en solitaire
et sans escale vous entendrez les deux
skippers dans cette édition
tir à l'arc les archers de guyancourt en
organiser à tout au long du week-end
leur concours général une compétition
programmée tous les ans et qui attire
des têtes d'affiché cette année à thomas
faucheron archers de l'équipe de france
sur les jeux olympiques de 2012 étaient
présents plus de détails à suivre
karting jimmy elias sept ans a été élu
révélation de l'année à 2016 par notre
rédaction le jeune pilote à remporter
sept de ses dix courses pour sa première
saison dont le championnat de france
nous recevrons le crack évinois dans
quelques instants
gros plan à présent sur les principaux
résultats du week-end
on commence à 7,8 sport part de la voile
éric bellion et louis burton sont
toujours en course pour le vendée globe
les deux skippers évinois sont en train
d'atteindre le stade de la mi-course les
sportifs sont au large de l'australie
après 42 jours
louis burton est pour l'instant toujours
ancré à la 9e place du classement mais
il remonte sur le 8e thomas ruyant le
navigateur ne compte que 300 milles
nautiques de retard on écoute louis
burton il a enregistré une séquence ce
week-end bonjour à terre
bienvenue à bord d'un bureau vallée on
est amis cos
ouais on a passé le l'ami chemin ce
matin et puis maintenant
on s'attaque à la réparation de deux
chandeliers bâbord qui ont été arrachés
pendant le long bord tribord amure on ne
l'avait jusqu'ici à la 18e place on
retrouve le versailles et éric bellion
le skipper de comme un seul homme va
mieux après avoir failli abandonner il
ya moins d'une semaine le navigateur qui
je vous le rappelle est novice sur ce
vendée globe a enfin trouvé un peu de
répit après plusieurs jours compliqués
surtout du monde en solitaire
on regarde la vidéo bonjour à tous
voilà petits plats du midi on est entre
les deux dépressions
donc on est en train d'être au calme il
n'y a pas trop de vent encore voilà mon
petit intérieur quotidien depuis presque
quarante cinq jours et voilà je suis en
train de digérer tout ce que j'ai appris
sur moi pendant la la dépression à
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres de
l'imoca comme un seul homme d'eric
bellion le skipper peut compter sur de
nombreux soutiens le les mécènes et
financeurs sa famille et ses amis se
sont réunis jeudi dernier à paris à côté
de la tour eiffel pour débriefer la
course du verset y ait une soirée où
nous avons pu rencontrer son frère
guillerme il était au micro de tv fil 78
et de la perte et je redécouvre aussi à
eric du personnel dans ce vendée globe
je découvre à quelqu'un de très humble
quelqu'un de très simple qui sait
mondiale communiqué ben voilà c'est fait
baisse ses moments de doute et qui ose
dire tout haut ce que je pense la
plupart des marins engagés ce vendée
globe ose à peine dire ou même pensait
tout bas
on continue par du tir à l'arc les
archers de bus en cours ont organisé
tout au long du week-end leur concours
général une compétition programmée à
tous les ans et qui attire des têtes
d'affiché cette année thomas faucheron
archers de l'équipe de france sur les
jeux olympiques de 2012 étaient présents
le montage est signée accuser les gens
de la précision de la concentration
c'était la recette pour remporter le
concours annuel organisé depuis 25 ans
par les archers de guyancourt
cette année 26 ils ont été installés
dans le gymnase maurice baquet pour
programme des duels pour mettre les
compétiteurs dans les conditions d'un
championnat officiel donc les gens font
leurs tirs sélectifs et à la fin nous
mélangeons par arm les personnes pour
leur faire un classement ce qu'on
appelle un classement scratch et on
retient les 16 meilleurs de ceux qui ont
décidé de participer aux finales
un programme qui a séduit les archers de
la région parisienne le tournoi affiché
complet avec plus de 240 participants le
samedi et 104 pour le dimanche
je suis toujours fiable participer parce
que c'est vraiment des gens super où il
ya vraiment une bonne ambiance et puis
ce principe de faire des concessions et
des duels c'est vraiment très bien dans
la mesure où il ya très peu de clubs qui
organisent des finales il ya beaucoup
darche et qui viennent rechercher cet
entraînement et du coup il ya de très
bon marché dont le niveau est tout de
suite beaucoup plus relevée que
d'habitude
parmi les archers des têtes d'affiché
sébastien peineau champion du monde
individuel en quarts en 2016 est venu
supporter les sportifs thomas fauchereau
membre de l'équipe de france sur les jo
de 2012 est lui venu se tester avant la
nouvelle saison à titre personnel j'ai
fait pas mal de changements techniques
en début de saison
des changements majeurs donc le but
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment d'essayer de
poser les changements que j'ai effectués
et de dérouler ma technique le plus
convenablement possible thomas fauchon a
remporté la finale de l'arc classique
hommes face à valentin ripaud rendez
vous l'année prochaine pour une nouvelle
édition
pas de football ce week-end dans les
yvelines mais du futsal plus de 200
enfants âgés de 6 à 13 ans se sont
affrontés sur les terrains de handball à
l'occasion du tournoi de noël de l'usb
en cours l'occasion pour les équipes de
tv fil 78 de vous présenter cette
discipline qui compte plus de vingt
mille adeptes dans l'hexagone
nicolas landry a pour les images
le football était à l'honneur ce samedi
17 décembre à guyancourt l'équipe de
football de la ville organisé au gymnase
de l'aviation un tournoi de noël pour la
18e année consécutive l'événement
encadrés par les éducateurs du club
était ouvert à plus de 200 enfants âgés
de 6 à 13 ans ça permet un à tous les
joueurs se connaître ils se fréquentent
se voir mais ne se connaissent pas de
mélanger les catégories permet une
cohésion meilleur la connaissance de
nouvel éducateur qu'ils auront peut-être
années suivantes des matchs de dix
minutes ont opposé deux équipes mixtes
de cinq joueurs les parties se sont
jouées sur les terrains de handball
dimensions de 40 mètres sur 20 m les
sensations très différent des terrains
de football en herbe à l'eau car elle
est moins de 800
et il fait - il fait moins froid à
l'intérieur
sachant que le terrain il un peu plus
petit je crois
ouais on va dire bah faut faire des
allers-retours un essai local ailleurs
il n'ya pas droit aux tacles des trucs
comme ça
avec cet événement le club espère
développer encore un peu plus ce sport
on l'a mis en place il ya quatre ans
forcément on va essayer de booster cette
pratique
on est un peu coincée par bien entendu
il nous faut des salles pour l'instant
on est un peu de ce fait l'armée
pourquoi pas le futsal compte près de
20me licenciés dans l'hexagone 25% de
plus qu'en 2011 un mot de boxe à présent
l'élan courtois a dit lahm ou mady a
bien négocié son retour sur les rings
absent depuis avril dernier l'illinois
réussi à battre ce samedi à noisy le
grand
l'ukrainien chez l'efs dans la catégorie
des poids super moyens le combat a été
arrêté à la 8e reprise par arrêt de
l'arbitré le boxeur de 36 ans devrait
maintenant se relancer dans la conquête
d'un titre européen dans les prochaines
semaines un titre qu'il avait abandonné
en avril dernier contre le britannique
kelly smith ce samedi à noisy le grand
il n'y avait pas qu'adil hamouma dit sur
le ring l'élan courtois à marvin petit a
également combattu pour un match de
préparation contre la gabonais ring
nguema le boxeur du 78 remporté la
victoire aux points au huitième rang d'
la fiche désormais un bilan de 19
victoires un nul et une défaite depuis
ses débuts en professionnel prochain
combat pour le sportif le 21 janvier
prochain contre l'espagnol santana à
levallois on va maintenant parler de
karting pour cette dernière émission de
l'année à 2016 dit milhas a débuté cette
discipline cette année à seulement à
sept ans le débutant à remporter cette
course sur dix dont le championnat de
france la coupe de france le prodige a
également participé au championnat du
monde en italie en octobre dernier un
palmarès long comme le bras qui en fait
selon le service des sports 2 tv fil 78
la révélation yvelinoise de l'année 2016
nous avons la chance de recevoir dans ce
magazine ce surdoué avec son père
cyrille alors on va te remettre une
petite coupe
voilà ceux ci ont marre si beau temps
titre d'illinois de l'année
félicitations merci beaucoup maintenant
des coupes
ah oui beaucoup beaucoup de coupes cyril
oui oui
non non on est on est on pensait pas en
avoir autant dhr cette année donc
on est super fiers de ce qu'a fait jimmy
cette année très impressionnés mais
alors on va parler du coût de ton
parcours téléspectateurs qui ne te
connaissent pas encore pourquoi as tu
commencé le karting cette année j'ai
commencé le karting à croise à esteban
au cou qui est un pilote de formule aura
futurs pilotes de formule ouais voilà je
vais t'en j'étais invité à déjeuner chez
lui à huy déjeuner chez lui et il m'a
fait ici et son simulateur et après
esteban appelé mon papa cyril et il est
venu voir et l'a dit que je compte juif
très bien il faut que tu le lin tant que
maître en karting
cl c'est vous qui la véracité ou aussi
un petit peu à se lancer ou pas du tout
ça s'est pas passé comme ça on était
chez donc la famille au conte qui sont
aujourd'hui en f1 et donc suite
enfin esteban a fait essayer un
simulateur à jimmy il était impressionné
par son coup d'oeil
il nous a dit mais il faut vraiment le
faire débuter tout petit en karting et
dès qu'on habille et au karting au bout
de quelques jours 10 nuits elle est déjà
très très vite ouais c'était
impressionnant
et qu'est ce qui te plaît dans le
karting jimmy c'est la vitesse s'est
doublée doubler la vitesse c'est surtout
ça oui il va très vite pour son alfred
celle j'ai jamais vu ça
moi j'ai jamais vu ces voix là je suis
sur le circuit depuis très longtemps
j'ai c'est la première fois que j'ai
aujourd'hui s'entraîne avec un kart
beaucoup plus puissant aujourd'hui jim
il roulait avec un kart qui va à 120
km/heure et il maîtrise à comme un
enfant qui joue au lego quoi de son âge
je le disais précédemment jimmy a
presque tout gagné cette saison sauf les
championnats du monde où il était
disqualifié c'était attendu vraiment
qu'il arrive à ce niveau là aussi
rapidement non non
très sincèrement je pensais qu'il aurait
fallu trois quatre ans avant d'arriver à
ce niveau là et
je pense même que sans l'erreur qui a eu
la part d'un mécano aux championnats du
monde je pense vraiment qu'il aurait
vraiment pu gagner le championnat du
monde dès sa première année carte
comment gère-t-on un diamant brut comme
jimmy on le fait travailler des heures
et des heures sur sur le circuit où on
le laisse gérer ses performances sa
course n'ont écouté très sincèrement il
travaille normalement pas plus que les
autres mais comprend tout à une vitesse
impressionnante et sur la piste féin
essais on a l'impression qu'il fait ça
depuis qu'il est né
comment fais tu pour aller très vite
jimmy grâce à un moteur un moteur est
toi au niveau de ton pilotage est-ce que
tu arrives à assimiler rapidement les
trajectoires par exemple oui à chaque
fois oui
des coupes beaucoup ton frère qui est
tentant l'entraîneur également oui je ne
m'en plains pas il apprend vite très
vite très vite très vite fait incroyable
tu es un grand fan de lewis hamilton
triple champion du monde de f1
tulle a même battu cette année je sais
pas si tu le sais tu es devenu le plus
jeune champion national de l'histoire à
7 ans hamilton n'avait que neuf ans
c'est un vrai modèle pour toi hamilton
ah oui pas un très bon modèle
et quels sont les objectifs du coup pour
produire ces très ferme du mit le but
c'est dès l'année prochaine de faim de
tout gagner
le son but c'est de gagner l'année
prochaine l'année d'après et de devenir
champion du monde
le bus et voilà d'être champion du monde
a le plus tôt possible
voilà un titre international et
il aimerait vraiment en faire son métier
voilà merci à tous les deux est passé
sur ce bateau vous souhaite une année
2007 2010 être encore plus belle que la
précédente
c'est la fin à ce dernier 7,8 sport de
l'année 2016 merci de l'avoir suivi on
se retrouve le lundi 2 janvier pour un
nouveau magazine on se quitte par ce
chant de noël du rugby-club de
versailles à bientôt
je veux une nouvelle de la part du
rugby-club de versailles pour tv fil 78
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]